[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm becoming nonfunctional
practically, and it doesn't bother me
as much that people think that
I'm weird, or crazy, or drunk.
People think that I'm drunk,
really, I'm Tim Moutafis.
I'm 62 years old.
I'm an entrepreneur,
specializing in medical devices.
I have two boys, who are grown.
I have a wonderful wife, and I'm
looking to better my condition
to where it was before.
When he got the diagnosis,
we were stunned.
He's always been an
athlete, and not just, you
know, the weekend
warrior type, but we're
talking like biking
across Greece, and boxing,
and doing all these other things.
And I think my initial reaction
was panic, like how can this be?
Every time I have a challenge,
I'm tempted to resolve it.
So I saw this as an opportunity
to show who I am really.
He was determined to act as if this were
a minor inconvenience, and that I think
was the thing that really got me
to stop panicking and to think,
OK, I got to approach
this in a different way.
I mean I don't know
what I would have done
if he had just-- he you got
that diagnosis and said,
oh my god, I'm done.
These three traces are
of three electrodes.
The top one is the anterior one.
The middle one is in the middle.
And this one is a posterior one.
So, right now it's pretty quiet.
Kind of like in a oscilloscope
this is a one second sweep.
And when we see neurons, you'll see
the little vertical deflections.
Those are single action
potentials of neurons, OK?
Ok, so I'm going to stop
here for just a second,
and check the impedence
of the electrodes,
now that I'm confident that
they're out of the cannula.
My first concern was what do I say to
my kids, because that was a concern.
And, you know, kids are very good.
They pick up on things.
You don't have to say a whole lot.
They kind of can see
where things are going.
And so I did talk to them about it.
But they also took their
cues from their dad,
who once he was diagnosed with
Parkinson's, within the first couple
of years said, OK, so
let me make up a plan
here that I think will
help me in the long run.
So windsurfing was something he
took up after he was diagnosed with
Parkinson's.
Part of my protective nature is I want
to make it all better, like right away.
And I've learned to trust him.
Initially, when we started
windsurfing, which, you know,
it was-- and on the open water.
OK, we're talking ocean.
It scared me to death.
And I was all over him.
Do you remember that one
time the coast guard came by?
I took a long rope, and I
tied myself to the shore.
And then I windsurfed
the best way I could,
so it took me a couple
of seconds to do that.
This is out on the open ocean.
OK, so that scared me a little bit.
Wait, you tied yourself to shore?
Right.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, how long was the rope?
It was about a 1,000 feet or so.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I was able to go back and
forth, but if there was a boat
to cross the rope, then we
would have had a problem.
OK, we're going to go
ahead and get started.
Open and close your hand.
Good.
The light bulb.
Show me how you turn a screw driver.
Good.
Say, I love tapioca pudding.
I love tapioca pudding.
OK, alright.
Do it again.
Open and close your hand.
That looks good.
Do the light bulb.
Nice, how's it feel to you?
Same?
Better?
Or worse?
Same to better.
It looks looser to me.
It looks more fluid.
Try it again.
Open both of your hands.
Do the light bulb.
Any unusual sensation Numbness?
Tingling?
Anything like that?
You OK?
No.
No, you're not OK?
No I'm not.
Is he having trouble talking?
There is a little face pulling.
Ok go back down.
To four?
To zero.
OK, feel better now?
Yeah.
And, you know, this is a
really like quick and dirty
test, so it's much finer when you
get it tested in the office, OK?
So, I'm just going to
secure everything in place.
And then close up.
Feel free to relax, close your
eyes, take a nap, whatever.
That's fine.
OK.
You ok?
Great job!
I think there's a lot of hope
in terms of what's out there.
So, there's so much
research going on right now.
So, I'm hopeful that the deep brain
stimulator will give us-- buy us
some time until the next big thing,
and then we'll go from there.